bon un prof universitaire c'est vraiment
le comble je suis vraiment dans de beaux
draps
qu'est-ce que j'ai bien pu faire on sent
bon soir mais qu'est ce que je vais vous
dire ça y est tout le monde là c'est bon
alors
en fait il faut que je vous dise que je
suis bien embarrassée parce que j'ai
perdu la mémoire
j'oublie ce que j'allais vous dire
alors je me suis ramené avec mes papiers
vous savez un on peut me demander mes
papiers donc je me suis armé avec ça
pourrait servir un au cas où
en fait si j'ai des trous de mémoire
c'est parce que dans ma tête ça tourne
pas rond
hier j'étais à une table ronde est un
des intervenants à qui personne n'avait
rien demandé a longuement pris la parole
pour ne rien dire
c'est d'ailleurs souvent le cas dans les
tables rondes et comme il n'a pas voulu
lâcher le morceau
pardon le micro je lui ai dit gentiment
imaginer imaginez que l'univers soit
infinitésimale petites molécules de rien
du tout une petite molécule composée de
milliards de galaxies comprenant des
milliards des toiles etc autour de ces
étoiles pour le des planètes et quelque
part comme ça a perdu dans l'océan
intergalactique
il y en ait une la terre la terre
probablement le seul petit point
microscopiques qui comprend des
continents des pays des villes des rues
des habitations etc
vous imaginez
eh bien il a fallu que par un drôle de
concours de circonstances de hasard ou
de nécessité
tout dépend du point de vue bien sûr je
me retrouve là en face de vous ici et
maintenant et que vous vous prenez pour
le nombril du monde mais bon sang de
bonsoir qu'est ce que moi j'ai fait au
bon dieu pour me retrouver dans une
situation pareille
le tout petit bonhomme du haut de sa
grandeur venait de prendre conscience
que nous ne sommes rien d'autre que des
passants des êtres insignifiant et
qu'avant et après nous il y avait et il
y aura encore des êtres vivants beaucoup
plus important que nous eh bien
aujourd'hui je vais commencer mon propos
par là en effet soit la terre est la
seule planète qui connaît la vie et dans
ce cas en tant que super prédateur doté
de conscience nous en sommes directement
responsable et on a intérêt à faire un
peu moins les les intéressants et à
penser aux générations suivantes soit la
vie existe ou est possible ailleurs et
alors bas il faudra très vite là tout de
suite c'est à dire dans quelques
centaines d'années où des milliers
d'années trouvé le moyen de prendre nos
clics ne claque quitter le plancher des
vaches
parce que avec notre inconscience un
notre petit orange bleu et ben ça va
devenir une gigantesque poubelle à ciel
ouvert c'est quand même étonnant cette
espèce de primate hominidés qui sur une
échelle de 24 heures depuis la création
de la terre ne correspondant qu'aux
dernières secondes et qui en l'espace
d'un temps très court donc à par
ignorance ou profit gachet et quasiment
épuisé un peu plus d'une centaine en un
peu plus d'une centaine d'années les
énergies fossiles que la terre a mis des
millions d'années à façonner
on produit trop on consomme trop on
exploite trop en pensant que votre
petite pomme
en un siècle la population humaine a été
multipliée par quatre et la consommation
de l'énergie par dix pendant ce temps là
les activités polluantes qui provoque
des millions de morts chaque année on
causait des changements climatiques le
réchauffement de la planète
la fonte de la banquise et des grandes
l'acier la désertification du tiers des
terres tous les jours nous défrichons
des centaines d'hectares de forêts
véritable poumon de la planète et des
dizaines d'espèces disparaissent de
manière irréversible
vous imaginez vous imaginez un peu que
les enfants de vos enfants le jour avec
des nounours en peluche tout simplement
parce que un ours polaire pour les
enfants de vos enfants
ce sera l'équivalent d'un dinosaure pour
nous depuis quelques années les abeilles
cette merveille de la nature ce petit
insecte de rien du tout eh bien les
abeilles ça ne se reproduit plus au
rythme naturel sa peau les lisent de
moins en moins et à cause des
insecticides de destiner soi-disant à
protéger leurs récoltes
1 et ben qu'est ce qui se passe on veut
tuer des parasites mais c'est qui les
parasitent tu es une abeille aujourd'hui
c'est jouer avec le futur de nos enfants
c'est ce que l'on appelle l'effet
boomerang 1 celui qui sème le vent
récolte la tempête
savez vous que 700 millions de personnes
pâtissent d'un manque d'eau potable et
que les statistiques de l'unesco indique
que d'ici 2050 trois milliards de
personnes souffriront de la soif et que
la surpopulation nous obligera à nourrir
autrement
faut pas croire mais 2050 c'est c'est
maintenant un c'est tout à l'heure là
tout de suite dans quelques tours de la
terre et puis ça va vite ça va très très
vite
ça va tellement vite que si ça continue
comme ça un de ces jours la terre elle
va nous jouer un sale tour 1
et puis on a plein dans son sac détour
en parlant de sacs les hypermarchés les
hypermarchés du futur eh bien ils
vendront des sacs en gros et en détail
plainte de poudre d'insectes en guise de
protéines animales pour remplacer les
biftecks parce que des biftecks y en
aura plus et les riches ils auront des
compléments alimentaires des compléments
nutritifs avec des plantes déshydraté
quant au pauvre ben ils se nourriront
avec la pilule pilule qu'aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs certaines personnes oublient
par méconnaissance ou par mégarde de
prendre et qui après viendront vous dire
que c'était la graine du bon dieu c'est
ça mon oeil oui on s'amuse en cachette
entre nous et c'est toujours la faute du
facteur de lettres de lettres pas de
lettre du facteur de lettres reparaître
on est passé de lettres paraître et
lorsque ça ne va pas pour une raison ou
une autre alors on imagine que tous nos
maux sont soit le fruit des aléas de la
nature soit la volonté d'une puissance
spirituelle céleste qui pourtant je peux
vous l'assurer m'a rien à voir avec nos
élucubrations terrestre elle est
franchement forte cette espèce de habas
ayé j'ai un trou de mémoire
cette espèce de jeu c'est plus comme on
les appelle
ah oui ça me revient à l'esprit les
animaux les alliés mots voilà c'est
l'expression employée à la télé par une
petite dame qui poussa un cri de
détresse qui avait traité certains
soi-disant politichiens eux
excusez moi du lapsus révélateur je ne
voulais pas dire politichiens quoique
donc certains politiciens et bien cette
petite dame les avait traités de valimo
de véritable caméléon dont les vêtements
dans un futur proche changeront de
couleur en fonction de leur état d'un
état d'un état d'âme
parce que tu as d'hommes il faudra s'en
va sur et état de droit
encore plus état de droit non mais de
toutes les manières les animaux quand
ils ont pas le droit
eh ben ils prennent le gauche ils sont
tellement gonflé gonflé aux hormones
j'entends bien ils sont tellement
gonflée aux hormones qu'ils en oublient
le goût le dre le naturel
pendant que certains laboratoires
s'amuse à créer des virus afin de se
faire du blé en mettant par la suite sur
le marché des antivirus
d'autres font des expériences génétiques
en vue de fabriquer en l'espace de
quelques jours des ogm du blé du blé à
gogo ils vont se faire du blé à gogo
avec du blé et des animaux hyper musclé
dont la chair insipide inodore sera
prête à être directement consommée dans
nos assiettes
ça me rappelle une certaine pub ça a le
goût de l'eau d'heure 2 mais ce n'est
pas comme là bas a dit eh bien tant
mieux qu'ici ce soit pas comme là-bas à
l'être humain d'êtres humains c'est
comme ça qu'on dit on dit être humain ou
avoir humain si ces pourparlers
d'auxiliaires on l'est véritablement on
devrait plutôt dire la chose humaine la
chose chose car tellement égoïste que
n'est pas fichu de coopérer
pacifiquement de partager les ressources
équitablement et de transmettre la
connaissance et les découvertes l'être
humain ne pense qu'à ça oui au fait donc
j'y suis c'est vrai qu'on pense l'homme
ah oui ils pensent qu'à ne pense qu'à ça
un vicieux c'est un obsédé qui ne
pensent qu'un cas tirer profit à tirer
sur les ficelles pour accumuler des
richesses
or l'argent tel que nous le connaissons
aujourd'hui comme moyen d'accéder à un
certain pouvoir
appelée à disparaître d'une manière ou
d'une autre à l'image des ressources
naturelles
s'il semble infinie et indestructible en
réalité c'est un colosse aux pieds
d'argile dont l'individu une fois
dépourvu donnera bien label de rap bel
et bien avoir ce qu'il cache en lui
et là ça résonnera sa résonnera sans
raisonner il n'est pas bull tableau 1
il faut pourtant pas ne pas s'inquiéter
car le futur c'est vous vous cette
jeunesse d'aujourd'hui parce qu'un
former éduquer et sage parce que vous
êtes le monde et que la solution est en
vous vous serez le changement que vous
voulez vous voir venir c'est vous parce
que vous le désirez qui trouverait à
créer une énergie non polluante et
illimité parce que vous aurez découvert
les aigles et part donc les structures
internes de la matière votre désir de
savoir est tel que j'en ai la certitude
sans en être convaincu
quoique con vaincu peut-être quand même
un peu que la compréhension du génome
humain permettra de re faire pousser
n'importe quel organe déficient et de
lutter contre les maladies dégénératives
un sigle de guérir la plupart des mots
vous retarderait la vieillesse vous
aurez moins la grosse tête que nous et
surtout comme ça me regarde quand même
un petit peu de près les handicapés et
bin 5 aura plus les rues quoi que courir
ça n'a jamais vraiment été votre fort
bah oui à quoi bon courir et courir
derrière quoi derrière le temps quelle
belle peau qui eux pardon quelle belle
jambe ça me fait un
d'ailleurs vous savez peut-être que
c'est parce que je ne peux pas courir
que je fais dans le discours ir et que
je suis devenu prof universitaire on
fait ce qu'on peut avec ce qu'on a
on s'adapte on s'adapte il faut bien se
donner de temps en temps un peu de temps
pour
regardez les choses autrement regardez
regardez moi par exemple j'ai une chance
inouïe la vie la nature m'a donné une
chance inouïe c'est celle de ne pas
pouvoir marcher dans rapidement et bien
le fait de marcher lentement
ça me donne le temps de regarder les
plantes poussent et et ça c'est pas
donné à n'importe qui je vous assure que
je ne vous fais pas marché c'est vrai il
suffit que vous et un manque d'un côté
pour que naturellement de l'autre ça
s'équilibre faut savoir juste voir les
choses du bon côté c'est tout mais avec
la terre avec la terre ça ne marche pas
comme ça parce que ce n'est pas dans ma
nature mais nous qui handicaperont la
terre
trêve de plaisanterie faut vraiment
qu'on arrête nos bêtises et qu'on
commence sérieusement à passer de la
vanité à l'humilité et qu'on comprenne
une bonne fois pour toutes que le
développement durable et le respect de
la diversité est une condition
sinequanone de notre survie et de celle
des générations futures
au delà de tout intérêt partisan au de
la dap d apparence physique
au delà des appartenances culturelles au
delà du social du religieux de
l'idéologique du politique
réfléchissez à deux fois
réfléchissez à deux fois avant de
gaspiller quoique ce soit et vivait avec
une simplicité volontaire sans artifice
aucun vous n'aurez plus alors à vous
inquiéter pour votre avenir et encore
moins pour celui de votre descendance
garder à l'esprit que comme disait
charles darwin les espèces qui survivent
ne sont pas les plus fortes ni les plus
intelligentes mais celles qui s'adaptent
le mieux aux changements pour ce qui est
des changements nous en tunisie on
connaît le changement on n'a pas à se
plaindre hein
tout va bien on en connaît un bon bout
et depuis
eh ben on a changé ça n'a pas l'air mais
comme ça mais on se cherche
ben qu'on pense
cherchant se trouve mais a toujours en
s'y retrouve en un
il arrive aussi que on se cherche la
petite bête
bon mais ça c'est juste pour nous amuser
entre nous pour passer du bon temps
c'est juste le temps de prendre
conscience que nous avons une chose que
nous avons une chance inouïe d'être là
où nous sommes
car rien qu'avec le soleil nous avons de
quoi produire suffisamment d'énergie
pour la terre entière de l'énergie tant
électrique humaine car le soleil ça
réchauffe ses importe la bonne humeur
il suffit juste de le vouloir pour le
pouvoir et d'y mettre un peu de bonne
volonté
enfin pour finir
permettez-moi de vous rappeler que vous
êtes notre seul et unique espoir
vous êtes notre seul et unique espoir en
lequel nous avons une foi indéfectible
pardonnez-nous nos bêtises et ne
trahissez pas nos attentes car à votre
tour vous en aurez ainsi est faite la
vie c'est chacun son tour
et comme disait je ne sais plus trop qui
probablement aussi si ma mémoire ne me
joue pas de tour la comtesse de
pompadour et bien la comtesse de
pompadour
elle disait avec un accent si
particulier pourvu que ça dure pourvu
que ça dure c'est à dire et bien que ça
continue à tourner sans nous faire
tourner la tête et encore moins tourner
en bourrique
vous devez rêver et osez vous devez
rêver aux et osé alors rêver et osez
osez autant que votre imagination le
permettra et vous le pourrez ainsi vous
écrirez votre histoire
la véritable histoire de cet homo
sapiens sapiens qui jusqu'à nos jours
n'en est qu'à sa période de
balbutiements je vous remercie pour
votre attention et à bon entendeur salut